so there's some there's some signals
that exist in the record books right and
to some that means the aliens have
already tried to contact us in 1977 the
Ohio State University had a big radio
telescope it's been turned and I think
into a golf course now but one morning
and one of the astronomers that got that
name is Jerry Amon he comes in and he
looks at the last night's observing
which is all printed out on paper that's
the way computers you still worked and
he's going through his papers and
remembering paper oh yeah and he finds
his big signal and he writes with a
magic marker he writes Wow
next to it so that's become known as the
WoW signal now the big question was
could this have been the aliens trying
to get in touch with Ohio and the answer
is we don't know the answer because that
instrument automatically looked again 70
seconds later a little over a minute
later and didn't find the signal people
have continued to look for it we've been
looking for it and we haven't found it
either so what do you conclude from that
it could be that the aliens broadcast
once and then went on vacation it could
be but you would never call that science
if you don't find it another time we
can't repeat it so I this one and how
about the kepler object that had this
weird eclipsing material in orbit around
the host star yes KIC 8:46 2852 kind of
rolls off the tongue yeah this is a star
that's quite far away actually it's
almost 1,500 light-years away that's
pretty far from most stars and it is
seen you you know you kepler measured
its brightness over the course of years
really and you know stars don't change
their brightness very much but this one
suddenly dipped in brightness by more
than a fifth 22% very unusual the Sun
never does have thank goodness okay it
wasn't because it was a planet going in
front of it that would never dim it that
much so the question is what was it and
one suggestion made maybe semi seriously
was well maybe there's a civilization
there and they build some Astro
engineering project which is blocking
some of the light and they're taking
that energy and feeding their planet
with it for example they could be doing
that so-called Dyson Sphere yeah yeah
okay so now just keep it in the list
here a few months ago Russians made in
an hour
of possible a radio signal that could
represent intelligent life indeed the
Russians back in 2015 had used a big
antenna down close to the Caucasus it's
called a rat an 600 it's from the Soviet
era you know had big women turning
cranks and stuff like that but it's a
big antenna and they found a signal
coming from the star HD 1645 95 another
wonderfully named star that stars known
to have planets and they thought maybe
this is it but they didn't make any
noise about it they didn't tell people
and that's a strong indication that they
themselves thought it might be
interference but somebody wrote a blog
about this and so you know for a week
the media went nuts about this star we
tried to check out the signal the
Berkeley people tried to check out this
signal no signal the Russians were kind
of forced to announce look we think it
was a military satellite
[Music]